there are many laws you and I can break
and will face a weekend in prison a DUI
could get you a weekend in prison a
month in prison three months a year two
years three years five years but there
is a law that the sentence is a life
sentence of imprisonment - the bars -
the inmates it's you against you and
that laws a la familiarity law of
familiarity has a tendency of getting
the best of all of us I read a quote one
time that said sometimes you will never
know the value of a moment until it
becomes a memory sometimes you will
never know the value of a moment until
it becomes a memory I am right now at
Los Angeles National Cemetery there are
thousands of people here services being
done parents crying spouses crying
people in there under knees praying and
brought my wife and my father and my
kids here because it's my job as a
father to remind my boys that listen
none of this stuff we have in America
here's for free none of it is I remember
I was 2001 when I was taking my series 7
exam at Morgan Stanley Dean Witter I
would go to the cemetery Forest Lawn and
I would study for my series 7 right next
to my grandmother's plot it was my space
away from everybody and it was a way for
me to know you got to give everything
you got cuz this thing goes by quick and
you got to give everything you got cuz
your family sacrificed everything to
bring you to this country you see the
law familiarity I didn't have to we
don't have to worry about war many times
in American a lot of times we don't know
the value of soldiers you know I got
John Francis morals here world war ii
ralph locky US Navy world war ii joseph
Ariano
Oliver crooks world war two Frank Walker
world war two you know how long it would
take me to go through all these names
here would take me a few days to go
through it it's not a couple thousand
there's tens of thousands just here not
including places all around the country
so you know I may have been born in Iran
but I'm definitely made in America and
Iran had to worry about the bombing and
people passing away and how terrible it
was in America we don't because we have
a very strong military that gets us to
not even think about our military so
what's the message really here all about
what can we do to fight against the law
of familiarity there is a solution for
that the solution is a constant state of
gratitude a constant state of gratitude
for your parents even though they tick
you off at times a constant state of
gratitude for your kids even though they
take you off at times my kid had 105
degree temperature 105 and a half three
days ago my oldest son and late at night
he can't sleep he's just wait pick him
up you don't even know how to feel him
he's just wait on top of you and I had
to be in the bathtub with him Jennifer
my wife constantly working with this kid
and what we used to get upset about and
now we're happy about
now he's punching again now he's
pinching again now he's throwing stuff
again isn't it interesting that the
stuff we were upset about two weeks ago
now we're grateful for because he's got
his energy back the law familiarity
gratitude is the solution constant state
of gratitude for your family your
business your mentors the people you
work with the country you live in the
heritage you have the lineage you come
from the financial situation you're
currently in your health conditions
constantly constantly constantly be
grateful so if you got some people in
your life
call him send him a text out of nowhere
just tell him hey man hey mom hey dad
I'm grateful for you I'd smile let you
know thank you and tell him why be
thankful for them this thing goes by
quick there's a lot of validation here
100% of us are gonna be gone one day and
we have 60 70 80 90 years to make a
difference so the next time you see
somebody was in a military in a mall
Airport restaurant don't let them pay
for their bill pay for their lunch pay
for the coffee thank them for what they
did if you can't pay for it at least go
up to them and thank them for it but let
them know be appreciate about what they
do on a daily basis because without them
we would not be free to do the things we
want to do with the people we love
it's my message of the day and the week
to you I've been Memorial to everybody
take care bye-bye